hey team it's Charlie so they just
announced some of the actors that are
coming on this year's Christmas special
so I wanted to do a bonus video for that
as well as talk about my favorite guest
actors that have been on the specials
the new people they just announced our
really exciting so I think they're gonna
go down to some really memorable
characters and just a quick reminder the
giveaway is still running till I post my
Q&A tomorrow I'll explain again at the
end of this video in case you have
absolutely no idea what I'm talking
about so starting off with Christmas
special casting and updates the BBC
officially just announced five new guest
actors or joining the Christmas special
there's Nick Frost of Cornetto Fame
Michael Troughton the second doctor son
of course Nathaniel McMullen from
misfits Natalie gamete from Coronation
Street and Faye marsay from glue the
person I'm most excited about is Nick
Frost
he was seen earlier this week walking
around the set with Dan Starkey who
plays Strax they've been filming the
special at Satan melons golf club and
vandura Hall in Cardiff here's actually
a couple of pictures at the Manor that
they've been filming around obviously
you have to imagine a lot of snow
because this is the Christmas special so
of course it's gonna be snowing now that
they've confirmed frost it also sounds
like the Paternoster gang or at least
Strax are gonna be in the special I
wouldn't expect Strax to be in it though
if the rest of the Paternoster was not
gonna be in it it kind of explains why
they're filming you're a Victorian
looking Manor they might be back in
Victorian times we don't really know
what the story is gonna be yet no word
on who Nick Frost is playing but the
best rumor that I've seen so far is
Santa Claus or at least someone very
Santa like it is Christmas so it doesn't
sound so unusual that Santa Claus would
be in a Doctor Who episode now that 2/3
of the Cornetto gang are gonna have been
in Doctor Who
I feel like Edgar Wright's gonna have to
cave and direct an episode at some point
would it be crazy if all three of them
got together for the same episode it
would kill Doctor Who's budget but it
would be so amazing here's something
funny though Edgar Wright admitted that
Russell T Davies offered him the job of
directing the 2005 episode Rose that's
the series 1 debut he said he had to
turn it down because he was working on
Shana the dead and his mother has not
forgiven him ever since could you just
imagine what that episode would look
like if he directed it no idea on who
Michael Troughton or any of the other
guest cast reply
there's really two ways that it could go
it could be a straight up one off like
the 2011 Christmas special the doctor
the widow in the wardrobe or it could
deal with the aftermath of the series
eight finale right now with all the
rumors about Jenna Coleman leaving I'm
leaning towards the second option I feel
like it's gonna be a continuation in
some way of the finale it would be a
nice book into the Missy's storyline the
doctors face and explaining how they're
gonna proceed into series 9 with all the
teasers especially from the next episode
about Clara having problems trying to
balance a normal life with being a
companion I'm thinking that in her head
she's starting to think about leaving
whether or not the actress Jenna Coleman
is thinking about leaving so here's the
big question
let's look at some of the images from
the teaser for that next episode look at
her face do you think that this is the
face of a companion that's gonna stay or
does it look like Clara wants to have a
go at being normal
I'm still crying about the way that Amy
and Rory left so if Clara really does
leave I can only imagine how it's gonna
go down
I think a lot of that's gonna depend on
how the rest of series eight goes so
we'll just have to wait and see but I
try to keep an open mind when it comes
to companions so I won't make my final
judgement on Clara till after series
eight with the Christmas special in mind
though here are my top five guest actors
to start in a special I'm just counting
the Christmas specials to number five
Lindsey Duncan from waters of Mars of
all the female guest stars during the
David Tennant specials she felt like the
most badass and how cool is it that she
showed up in Sherlock series 3 last year
I'm not completely familiar with all of
our work but just based on her Doctor
Who material whenever I saw her in
Sherlock I felt like she was gonna be a
badass
and even though I'm mostly just talking
about the actors themselves and not
necessarily the characters that they
played in the specials I feel like I
enjoyed her character Adelaide Brooks
the most out of the temporary companions
and I do consider the Christmas special
companions temporary companions when I
say that either way she was definitely
the smartest and one of the few female
companions that did not automatically
start fawning all over the doctor to be
fair though they were being hunted down
on Mars so there was not a lot of time
for romance but number 4 Richard II
grant in the snowmen he's one of the few
actors I could legitimately be afraid of
without having to put on a lot of
prosthetics or voice manipulation like
nickels Briggs doing Dalek voice there
are a lot of things that you could say
about the series since Moffat took over
showrunner a lot of things I'm sure but
I feel like he really pushed for
celebrity guest stars and the specials
much more so than Russell Davies
unless you count Kylie Minogue and
Timothy Dalton he did have some big
actors I don't want to sell him short
but grants dr. Simeon felt like a real
threat to the doctor without being too
crazy or over-the-top and has all due to
his performance I don't know that we'll
ever get to see him again on the series
just because of what they did with the
character I did enjoy Grant playing the
great intelligence during the series 7
finale but I really miss his dr. Simeon
but moving on to number 3 Ian McKellen
also in the snow Minh I went a little
bit nuts whenever I heard he was going
to be playing a character it made a
little bit more sense when I found out
that he was just providing some
voiceover work until Richard E grant
took over the persona at the end of that
episode Ian McKellen is probably one of
the busiest actors in the world and if
you ever wondered why
Benedict Cumberbatch or other big actors
don't come on Doctor Who more often it's
mostly because of scheduling but the way
Gandalf made that giant snow globe scary
was so amazing I don't know if I'll ever
see that again on Doctor Who every once
in a while you see a villain or a
character there's so abstract it just
blows you away wouldn't it be crazy
though if he just had some brief walk-on
cameo and like a future special it would
spawn so many crazy great intelligence
paradox theories moving out to number
two Timothy Dalton in the end of time I
think when you consider all the big
a-list guest actors and the characters
that they played he is one of my
favorite on both counts there were some
really cool guest actors like David
Morsi who played really strange
characters usually when they cast big
people they give them really big roles
sometimes it just does not work out the
way you wanted to Dalton as Rassilon was
like watching Shakespeare Doctor Who at
its best he got to be the most infamous
person in the history of the Canon
probably next to Omega or the master
maybe and I feel like Russell Davies
just told him to go to town I can only
imagine what was going on on set they do
the Doctor Who extra now but I feel like
we're only seeing a fraction of what
goes on behind the scenes I'm always
really interested in that part of the
production whenever someone like Dalton
someone that good comes in usually
directors will just give them notes on
what they want help them stay on store
but what you get from them is so amazing
they don't need a lot of direction you
just sit and watch them melt your face
off with crazy monologues I would say
his speech at the end of end of time
part one is still one of my favorite
Doctor Who speeches of all time and my
number one favorite Doctor Who Guest
Actor in a special Michael Gambon
in A Christmas Carol how awesome is it
that Dumbledore agreed to come on Doctor
Who he didn't have to do that I feel
like for every big actor we see come on
ten
turned the series down for you know
various reasons I feel like I don't even
need to say too much about his
performance he's one of the greatest
living actors in the world right now add
to that he also just happens to live in
the UK which makes it a little easier to
get to Cardiff to film Doctor Who there
are a lot of amazing international
actors from all over the world but
because of the way a lot of the British
actors are brought up through the
theater I feel like they have a distinct
advantage whenever they do genre shows
like Doctor Who this is a personal
preference I like the genre that I watch
like science fiction fantasy to be
a little bit more theatrical even when
it's super depressing like Battlestar
Galactica I want it to be up in my face
and have a lot of dramatic weight even
if there's not a lot of special effects
that's why some of my favorite moments
from Doctor Who so far have been Capaldi
just talking to himself because he just
knows how to carry a scene without
special effects that requires a very
special type of actor that you don't
always find in America for example it's
one of the reasons why I am totally fine
with all future doctors being
exclusively British be they male or
female but now it's your turn let me
know who is your favorite guest actor in
a special I suppose you could totally
bend the rules and just include from any
of the specialists from classic ooh or
modern who not just the Christmas ones
quick update on more Doctor Who coming
the Q&A is gonna post tomorrow if you
want enter the giveaway all you have to
do is be a subscriber and leave a
comment generally giveaways are only for
people on the team that's tentatively
what I'm calling our extended family
here so if you'd like to talk about
Doctor Who science fiction and fantasy
be sure to subscribe and join the team
we would love to have you because I
stayed up way too late last night
working on my Constantine video I was
hallucinating a little during time eyes
to that effect here are a couple quick
Corrections from my review when I was
talking about the architect I was
actually thinking about the person who
designed the bank like the actual
architect not the
detective the plan to rob the bank who
was in fact the doctor and in regards to
the next episode yes the doctor is the
caretaker it's just because American and
British terms for school positions are a
little bit different
I was thinking caretaker meant principal
which in the UK is actually the
headmaster in America the caretaker of a
school is called the janitor and I
didn't think the doctor was going to be
the janitor of coal Hill it's just a
wonky language thing but the Q&A should
be up by mid afternoon tomorrow you can
click here to get it a lot of the
annotation as soon as I post it and you
can click here for my time highest
review now everybody let's high-five
real quick before I pass out from
exhaustion
you